so welcome first of all to tonight's
lecture on chess endings I had a game in
particular that I wanted to show you and
rather than just going through the whole
ending which is very very complicated
one
Oh embellish it with a few notes and
explanations going from the game first
of all I was in vikon's a Holland
vikon's a bike means village by the sea
vikon's a vikon's a was having I think
it's the 77th edition of the Vikon say
chess festival and it's obviously been
going on very very long it think it's
the second longest running event beside
Hastings in England which I think has
gone beyond a hundred years already
their event so in vikon's a the top top
chess stars were there Magnus Carlsen
and some of the world's very best
players and our own American now
American Wesley so then Wesley was
really really impressive he was doing it
tremendously well in the event and in
fact he had only one blemish one loss on
his record and that was against honest
Gary I noticed that recently and a Grand
Prix event honest Gary became the eighth
player only the eighth player ever to
cross the 2800 barrier and on Isha's
2,800 very very very impressive this
game honest Gary was white Wesley so is
black and as I mentioned it was a game
it was the only game that Wesley lost in
the event and on --is--
basically he is a player who likes the
cattle and very much and he plays it
with various systems c4 or d4 and Knight
f3 did he likes the Catalan and Wesley
was all ready for it and I think here we
see if very ambitious move by Wesley
perhaps it was due to the fact that he
was actually scoring so well in the
tournament
the most common move of course is Bishop
e7 and then we would get a proper cattle
and after this move order and Vladimir
Kramnik Levon Aronian or two of the most
prominent experts in the catalan but
certainly on ich is deserving as well as
he plays it very well for those reasons
Wesley
advanced his pawn d5 d4 very ambitious
move okay it stops white from playing d4
but it's a very big tempo to begin with
and then the question is whether or not
the pawn is going to be a target for
White's pieces first place Wesley
defends at the pond so we could get
after for example a move like b2 before
a Banco gambit reverse colors and whites
playing the black side of a Banco gambit
but e 2 e 3 is very sensible move and
now we have a Benoni position a reverse
Benoni and as you heard Mike he was
talking about the restrictive Bishop
yeah you want to get to Bishop out
before you get trapped behind your own
pawns well there you have it
so d3 Bishop d6 I thought again that
this was far too ambitious by black I
actually preferred that Wesley would
have played
the second Bishop e7 there are some very
concrete reasons why the bishop on d6 is
actually more of a target a tactical
target than on e7 Bishop d6 was played
Knight a3 e 7 E 685 and this is one of
those reasons c4 c5 and white is trying
to play Knight c4 and get to trade his C
pawn for black C pawn takes Knight 97
this was an error in my opinion at this
moment Knight d7 I didn't like at all
and I preferred I think it was a little
bit of G for just a second here let me
see if I wrote that down I believe I did
yeah this was my I was thinking that
black might be able to escape with a but
approximate equality after a line like
this I still have a slight preference
for white but I think that that would
have been a better choice than what
Wesley played in the game one Wesley
played in the game was 97 and he got a
position where it was formed bishops but
white first of all White's bishop on g2
is really excellent is really putting
some nasty pressure rook along the fifth
rank is also very active and this pawn
is actually in the way if it wasn't on
the board at the moment you know to be
ideas of Bishop takes F to check and
Queen f6 check or Queen d4 check but the
pawn on d4 is a liability Queen b6 was
played and I thought this was an
excellent move by honest a4 okay so just
ideas of a5 a6 taking
Vantage of this long diagonal as
previously mentioned Black has a very
very uncomfortable position
a5 was played Queen c2 Bishop before
roughly five Queen b6 Bishop f4 and
black justice getting more and more tied
up white wants to just simply develop
his rook there are there moments that
Bishop d5 is a very nice tempo the rook
could swing back to e5 and again rook c1
trying to come down with the Queen to c7
all very good Wesley decided it was time
to jettison upon played Bishop d7 and
the pond was captured so Wesley in very
big trouble here and frankly I thought
he was losing okay and it was remarkable
the fight that he put up but as to say
Wesley resisted it incredibly well at
this point on --is-- helped him a little
bit with the move Queen d1 which I
didn't understand
I thought honest would play Queen e2
which I thought was a very strong move
just to prevent the Bishop from coming
to e6 without compromising the pawns and
if black plays rook e8 Queen h5 is a
very nice move indeed Queens active your
pawn up everything's going in White's
favor
so Queen e2 Bishop e6 rook and we got a
lot of trades and we got to this
position
this is probably the worst position that
black that white could have achieved
from the extra pond okay
he had this nice extra pond with very
good bishops he traded off all of his
bishops to get into a major peace ending
and here I thought Wesley suddenly and
unexpectedly really had very good
chances whenever you get into a major
peace ending with Queens and rooks or
simply Queens the rule of thumb besides
who's ahead of material who's up upon
who's down upon it's really about King
position King position is crucial in
Queen endings as well as major peace
endings with Queen and rooks on the
board and thanks to this pawn on g3
Black has a very concrete and direct
idea as does white honest played b4 with
the idea that he's forcing the creation
of a passer on the Queen side and black
certainly does not want to allow the
move b4 b5 but it was exactly here
exactly at this moment that Wesley made
a huge mistake and had he played it in a
in the proper way I think he would have
actually made a draw here what do you
think let me take away the notation for
a moment probably you've all read the
notations and that was very cleverly
yeah
what do you think what black should do
why should black do to rescue his
situation
don't all shout out at one one move that
you may find attractive is for example
queen up three rook takes d4 rook e 2
which would be superb except for the
fact that your have a back rank mate so
first you have to deal with the back
rank mate as well as trying to create
your own threat and for that reason the
best move in the position was h5 which
is a very very very strong move after h5
honest would have had a real real
problem trying to rope in the wind so to
speak for example if he would to take
the pawn h4 whew and suddenly this
threat of h3 and queen g2 is really
serious if you take this pawn on h4
black has a it means sorry if you take
this pawn on h4
exposing the white king black has a very
direct frontal attack with rookie 6 just
a second rookie 6 and then you're
threatening rook g6 check Queen h1 check
ideas and suddenly these extra ponds on
the a file and the h-file are
meaningless as White's King is in sudden
danger so this idea of king safety is so
very vital h4 rook back h3
f 4 is the best I could figure out for
white white protects the G to square
black threatens rookie to with this move
Queen f3
White has to stop that move and now
simply back with Queen c6 and again if
you look at this position as opposed to
what happened in the game you will
really see that black has nice counter
play against White's Queen
it's also kind of funny the extra pawn
here if if this a pond was we're missing
white would have ideas of rook e1 and a6
and a7 and either supporting the pond
but in fact these extra pawn isn't very
good for white in terms of being able to
push his pond I actually think that
Wesley would have drawn the game rather
comfortably had he played h5 instead he
took now he played h5 and the timing is
all wrong
rookie 4 and blacks threats so now we
get into the proverbial queen and pawn
ending queen and pawn end games are
terrible they're really really awful a
lot of generalities general rules they
just really go out the window and a lot
of Queen and pond end games it's just
about concrete calculation you've got to
calculate really long lines and many
many lines you have to be familiar with
perpetual check patterns and again it
comes down to King safety pardon me I
think there was one thing I skipped here
just a second
hold on let me let me there was a what
yeah honest missed a very clear win I
thought just a moment yes so here each
this was the move I
so after rook takes d3 the rooks were
traded okay so we get to this position
and again in major piece endings major
piece endings the whole concept is king
safety along with the concept of king
safety is the idea of which player has
the initiative which player can better
attack the opponent's king well in this
exact position it's white who has the
attacking potential because we can see
that he could go check King here check
once White's King what for me ones
whites Queen is on this diagonal his
king is in perfect safety and blacks
king is not so this was an amazing error
by honest Gary in my view I just did not
expect that move at all the move I had
expected instead was check going on the
offensive King would have to come to h7
Queen goes to e4 check now this is a
very very common type of pattern that
when you get into such situation you
want to go Queen e5 and rook h8 check
and mate the problem with Queen e5 is
again the king safety issue you don't
want to allow Queen f3 so what you just
do is you advance the pot a6 the best I
could find for Wesley was to retreat the
rook and to bring back
the king and we get this rockin dick
okay so now in this rook ending
it's a whoops let me just do this I beg
your pardon this is a very very
important position for rook endings this
ending in this position very important
what black wants to do is simply put his
rook behind the pawn and then it's not
it's going to be impossible for white to
promote his pawn to a queen without
bringing his king all the way to be set
yeah once you get the rook behind the
pawned the King has to go all the way
over here well the king is making its
march all the way to b7 so that you can
make a clean I can gobble blacks pawns
on the King side yeah yes yes rook f8
this is like a very very key moment and
you mustn't miss it a 7 would be a
terrible move because the rook would
drop immediately back but rook f8 not
only attacks the pawn with picking up a
tempo with check but it's also
threatening to play a 7 followed by
Queen the only move for black is to play
rook back to d7 stopping both threats
now for example you play rook b8 now in
this example the black rook if not
coming behind the pod you see he has to
play King g7 sorry the white rook is not
stuck in front of the pawn rook to b7
rook on rook and now the white king can
just come all the way across and you
won't have time to eat any of the pawns
so King f3 and this is a winning
position an easily winning position for
white these rook endings are very very
tricky but here the important thing
whenever you get into a major piece
endgame and you're wondering should I
trade rooks or should I trade Queens one
of the first and most vital questions
you have to ask is who's King is in
greater danger okay if blacks King is in
danger don't trade rooks don't trade
Queens because maybe you could get a
checkmating attack what has happened was
that instead we got to this Queen ending
and again Queen endings are terrible
they're really really the worst types of
endings to try to understand or to try
to study or make heads or tails of I
remember how many of you read Alekhine's
to volume series Alekhine's best games
don't all have you guys feel what you've
got to look forward to it's wonderful
wonderful chess writing so Alekhine got
himself into a position where he was a
pawn down in the Queen ending any
sacrifice want first one pawn sacrifice
to second but on so he's three pawns
down in the Queen ending but he had a
past pump so Alekhine said that when he
was one pawn down he was sure he was
losing when he was two pawns down he was
pretty sure that he had drawn chances
and that when he was the 3rd pawn down
then he knew it was a draw it's like
wait a minute you know I'm trying to
learn and understand a chess and here's
a former world champion explaining why
it was better to be down three pawns
than one because his past bond forced
his opponent to give him a perpetual
check his pawn was huge in the position
this position is an incredibly easy win
for white incredibly easy all you have
to do is go Queen to b7 a-five a-six
a-seven queen with the Queen on the
lights where your king is untouchable
you can't you can't check you can't do
nothing
so it's game over so the only thing that
Wesley could possibly do is to open up
White's King to give himself more
opportunities to get a perpetual check
and so he had to really gamble and he
played the move g5 so white checked
checked' and offered the trade of Queens
can't trade Queens because this past
pawn will just win the game so Wesley
had to Wesley set up a cute little trick
he's hoping that white will push the
pawn so he could go double if it check
with a double attack tags check Queen a
3 now he has to take the pawn ok on the
surface it might seem that blacks
operation didn't help didn't help his
coughs White's Queen as beautifully on
this diagonal but for the moment Black
has an opportunity of playing h4 which
he didn't have when his pawn was on g7
so actually black has improved his
drawing chances have after he's mangled
his own pawn structure because it's all
about King safety so here I thought
Wesley had chances of saving the game
check here Shaq just a second sorry it
wasn't check
let me turn the notation back on here
okay so we have a long series at this
point again it looks very simple from
White's perspective he just wants to go
a five a six Queen back to be 7 a 7
Queen and his King is in perfect safety
how can black possibly stop white from
carrying out his plan your only chance
is to play h4 and H takes g3 so the idea
of what White's last move Queen a8 was
first of all to be able to advance his
pawn and then to meet h4 with Queen h8
check so he has to stop black from
playing h4 as well as promote his own
palm so King came back to g7 and here
again it was kind of a I don't know if
this is really so much fun for either
the spectators or the players but
there's a modern day time control the
modern day time controls go something
like this
you get two hours for your first 40
moves or so or in 90 minutes for your
first 40 moves but every time you make a
move you get a 30 second bonus so
sometimes when you're short on time it
that the players like to repeat a few
moves so that they can grant gain a
couple of minutes on their clocks so for
the next few moves what we were seeing
was that the players were simply marking
time so that they could gain time on
their clocks and we've got nothing
really has changed so much over these
last few moves okay so now we come to a
very key moment in the game and I think
that at this moment white on --is-- miss
his clearest and most concrete path to
victory he has played in the game
Queenie for which again is this kind of
moves that gain time on the clock
instead he should have played the simple
Queen b5 okay
offering the trade of Queens Queen G for
now it's a fight over who gets this
diagonal long die weite gives a check
black moves the king and finally you
push the pawn and again it's just a home
run it's a touchdown this guy's just
gonna go the coordination you only have
one chance and that is h4 you've got to
break up the safety of White's King a6
away we go
takes now on the surface it appears both
sides have gotten through their
respective plans on the one hand white
is making a queen on the other hand
black is doing his best to expose
White's King but here's a key moment
Queen f3 I also believe that a7 is
winning but after takes King takes
there's gonna be a lot of checks you got
to run all the way up the board close to
your Queen to escape the checks but this
one is a very nice move Queen f3 and
just a second Queen f3 so the idea here
is that you're going to use your F pawn
as a form of protection for your king so
for example if we play let me just move
my Queen all the way over to a4 Queen
takes g3 check yeah ooh
King has to go where would we like to go
with our king f7 so let's go over here
with our Queen check-plus so if we go
back with King g6 I go a 7 push if we go
check with our queen that's it
oopsy-daisy you get to clean
oopsy-daisy if we go check here I'm
using my F pawn so that there is no
check here so once again we'll go Queen
check King here and you can't go Queen
here because of the same reason
oopsy-daisy so you have to go back in
the variation and once again we've got
our King beautifully protected that
variation remarkably enough was not
played and the game went longer and
longer and longer now honest Gary of
course representing Holland and in
vikon's a there was a huge audience the
game got bigger and bigger because on
issue was winning this crucial game for
you know tournament victory so we I was
doing this show on the air we couldn't
go off the air and we're like hey sorry
well that's the end of the show we'll
tune in tomorrow to find out who won so
5 hours became 6 hours which became 7
hours and so forth and so on and it was
very strange we had these webcams so we
have this beautiful webcam photo
high-definition webcam photo and on one
side there's Wesley on the other side
there's on H but the camera and
wonderful audience shots as everybody
was you know you could see everybody
pointing and talk
amongst themselves but just a little bit
of the background with two other players
from the Challenger section also still
playing whoa
what was that you know like late at
night everybody you know everybody's
gone home you know and these two other
players are playing and I was struggling
with this Queen ending trying to explain
what was going on and I said okay well
that's out of respect go and see what
they were doing in their game so I go on
the computer and I go to the Challenger
section and I pull up their game guess
what a queen and Big Show know where
everybody'd know hard Queen endings well
let's see what how Wesley was able to
put up such resistance so there we have
what looks like a beautiful position for
white he stopping h4 he's on the
diagonal he's done everything right but
at the moment he's not advanced upon so
black just says okay I'll wait I'll wait
for you to do something and now we have
Queen b5 Queen g4 and we get this
position okay
a5 okay so now Amish is back on track
he's back to winning h4 remember those
lines with Queen takes Queen f3 now it's
very very different
what happened was we get to this
position this position and
a crucial moment right here Queen b6
okay
so honest has a very easy winning move
all he has to do is play the move King
to g1 so what's the difference remember
a moment ago when I was talking about
yeah how the F to pawn is a really nice
shield for whites King let's say we go
here let's say we go here we're we're
very happy we're ready to advance our
pawn again if we go back to stop it
check and again
White's got the ideal setup he's on the
long diagonal
there'll be no perpetual check instead
on each had an oversight he missed that
after Queen b6 King G - what move can
black play and then Queen c6 check would
be king g1 and we're back into that
winning situation h3 check they're a
great great resource suddenly and here's
the crucial difference that the pawn on
g3 is not a as good a defender as it's
not a good protection as the pawn on f2
very very often in Queen endings it's
much better to have the ponds that are
defending your King back on the second
or seventh rank as opposed to forwards
if we look at this position we can see
that there are more check possibilities
for black now like one of the most
standard perpetual check mechanisms
forgetting that the Queen defends g4 is
for black to be able to play Queen h1
check King g4 Queenie for chat and
just keep repeating the checks as often
as necessary so there's already one
perpetual check mechanism in the
position and on --is-- now has a very
hard slog ahead of him and here we go
we're seeing again that White's King is
vulnerable to different perpetual checks
this was another extraordinary moment in
this ending and again these players are
world world-class players so do not feel
bad if you don't understand Queen and
pawn endings because they they made a
quite a number of errors just a moment
ago you were you heard me explaining
that the pawn on f2 is much better
protection for the for the King than the
pawn on g3 the same holds true for black
that this pawn on f6 helps protect his
King a lot more from checks and I was
really shocked when Wesley played this
move f5 which I considered an extremely
bad move like extremely bad rule so
Queens u2 offering a trade of Queens
Queen a1 and now we see check now blacks
King is actually has to go up if blacks
King goes backwards then comes Queen
check a7 yes and you just queen
so King g5 Kings more exposed up here
and now
Wesley's Queen is in some ways kind of
ideal in chess at the chess board
there's a kind of a strange geometry at
times and this is a this is an ideal
example of a strange geometry the Queen
is actually in a perfect position on the
one hand it's in this corner so it's
defending
it's behind the pawn on the other hand
it's looking at this corner for an idea
of checking as well as h8 so it's like a
perfect billiard you know like in three
different directions that white black
wants to harass White's King yeah I was
kind of triangles and stuff okay so now
white decides that if he just tries to
go Queen b7 into advance as pawns well
there are checks coming and there's just
a repetition so what white decides he's
going to do is take his King and move it
all the way over to b7 so that he can
win the game by pushing his pawn and so
we have again a lot of checks going on a
lot of shacks and every time
oddish is ready to move his king over to
the Queen side Black has done something
to block White's event now at this point
something strange happened here with the
King on f3 Queen so it looks very
similar to position we had a moment ago
where the Queen's were all in the
corners here but something very strange
happened that this occurred
white was able to make a series of
checks where he managed to bring his
queen all the way back to the center
and advance his pawn at the same time so
but this was only possible because there
was a pawn
if this pawn was on f6 this would not
have been a check of course and blacks
King would have been in greater safety
because the King was exposed white had
this very nice maneuver which on --is--
executed very well he got this position
and he was able to advance his pawn to
a7 one of the key yeah one of the key
ways when you're upon ahead in a in a
queen upon endgame to win the ending is
to have a centralized Queen it's just as
a general rule it's it's incredibly
important to put your queen in the
center when you're trying to win as we
see in this case the defenders queen was
trying to check in the corner and do all
of as many checks as he possibly could
so there was a whole lot of more checks
and a lot of checks and eventually black
has run out of checks Queen a3 one of
the best winning mechanisms when you're
trying to win is to force your opponent
the defenders queen in front of the pawn
okay when the different like rooks
belong behind past pawn well so do
Queens so the Queen on a3 what honest is
trying to do is force his opponent's
Queen into a passive blockading position
which reduces his opportunities to give
perpetual check
and this is where the game ended yeah
one extra queen so this so this and this
ending was a very very important ending
not only for the final standings in the
tournament I believe at the end of the
tournament Amish Gary and Wesley so were
two of three players who tied for second
along with the Frenchman MVL Maxine
Bashar lagron and had Wesley gone this
game he would have been clear second had
he wanted he would have tied for first
so it was a very big big turn of events
and this ending has a lot of lessons but
it's like one of those endings where you
know experience you know really counts a
lot so I'm sitting there on the
sidelines and the computer engines are
whizzing and everybody's twittering and
saying could he have drawn and stuff
like this and I was watching as a number
of errors were being played by
world-class players one of the reasons
that happen is if you go back to let's
say the 70s and and earlier the
grandmasters of those ages a kappa
blanka Alekhine bud Vinick Petrosyan
they would adjourn they would adjourn
the game the game would be stopped for
hours sometimes days teams of analysts
and trainers would work on the position
and then the grandmasters would show
extraordinary technique and they would
win almost perfectly the game the in
modern chess the players have to play to
a finish there's no adjournments they
don't have the time to calculate
everything and to be precise and perfect
with their play no they have to just
play and
that that they're forced at times to
make errors how many of you actually
played queen endings I played a number
myself not too many a queen ending I
played was the it was described as the
game that that couldn't devour China
became that couldn't devour China okay
how did it go I was in the Chess
Olympiad in - in 1988 in Thessaloniki in
Greece and I was playing of course for
the United States team and us playing
against China and I had an adjourn game
of Queen pas
I had a queen and five pawns against my
opponent's Queen and four pawns and we
play from her for many hours and we
adjourned again and in the next
adjournment I had Queen and four pawns
it's green in three funds then we
adjourned again and this continued
literally until I had Queen and you know
each each recession we would trade a
pair of founds and the game went way
beyond 200 moves way beyond 200 moves
and well beyond like five six days
messed up all of the whole Olympiad
pairings and everything and in Seattle
in Washington we have a magazine that
goes for Washington Oregon and Idaho
State Pacific Northwest chess so on the
cover of the magazine was the start of
the game right you open up the magazine
and then the top all of the games and
and it was in an inside to drag it by
the way so like there's the body of the
dragons and then there's this text and
throughout the whole issue on every page
the dragon went to the end of the issue
because game like maybe my long
scheme ever these Queen endings are
really really hard for those of you
raise your hand on the Queen endings did
you struggle did you find them difficult
to understand
yes though it was very easy
but the Queen endings have their own set
of rules and it's sometimes I get bogged
down
I think endings learning endings are
absolutely vital but Queen endings are
quite less frequent I find then rook
endings or minor piece endings or King
and pawn endings so a lot of people
don't study Queen endings young man that
game ended in a draw
I couldn't devour China the game ended
in a draw oh boy everybody was
disappointed about 15 years later by the
way I was in Beijing and I went and I
visited the Chinese chess Association
and it's a beautiful building in Beijing
and the building which is devoted to two
games actually chess and the game of Go
okay it's both a dormitory like many
many players from around China go to
Beijing and they live at that building
they have dorm rooms and it has
cafeterias libraries playing halls you
name it it's there and I have met dr.
Lin Tang Lin thank so he was very sweet
man he was happy to see me and we
chatted and so forth and so on and he
said to me by the way I have a story to
tell you that you don't know and I go
yes what is it he said in thessaloniki
in 1998 he was the captain of the men's
Chinese team I go yes yes yes of course
and he said you played against Zhu Jun
our player and I go
yes is that the game that went 250 moves
he goes yes and for like five or six
days in a row we had adjourned each day
and the next day we have to play in the
morning at night so Livan had gotten up
every morning at night to go to the
tournament hall and to be there and wait
for the result and no result and he just
came perpetually every day so much so
that he had set his alarm clock and he
had gone to the tournament hall and he
had sat down in the tournament hall and
fell asleep only to wake up and realize
that the game had been finished the day
before it was necessary for him to get
up so he said you know he had been
carrying a grudge for 15 years any
questions about this Queen ending or any
questions about Queen endings in
particular young man so let me just put
one on the board for a second I'm going
to play poorly for both players okay the
variation check again I'm just going to
play poorly for both players so here is
a typical so this is one perpetual
checking pattern that is very typical
yeah now just imagine how good it would
be to have our pawn on f2 let's say you
could try to run away now you're hoping
that I will check on e 2 so that you
could interpose your queen yeah that I
don't want to do that I want to check
you like this and I want to just keep
you in this very typical perpetual
checking pattern yeah
and this is just really based on a lot
of experience right I mean the more you
play chess you see these these perpetual
patterns and they repeat themselves
constantly you're always seeing them and
I recall I had played one clean ending
where we had danced around and around
and around and I had made a draw I was
trying to make the draw and I claimed
the draw that the the the the checks
came in a sequence of like 21
consecutive checks where it was a three
move repetition right that we went round
around in circles and I remember another
Queen ending I had against Michael tall
and we had an adjournment and it was
very exciting a German because the I was
ahead in material I was better and it
seemed like there were 12 hands helping
me like the whole American team we're
all making moves showing me I have to
beat Michael tall and we did a run
around the rosies there is a very funny
pattern that I ended up winning the game
I was I was a head of material in that
game but this awareness you just have to
have this awareness of your King safety
that is like a crucial crucial element
as well as the past part of the
questions it's all good it's all good
the last thing I really did want to
emphasize was this moment back here when
they got into this queen and rook
position this queen and rook versus
Queen and rook position like white as
let's sorry let's go back here to this
moment if we stop at this moment white
just has everything he's got two great
bishops a very very powerful rook this
pawn on d4 is weak
and it was just remarkable how Aneesh
just went for a position of Queen and
rook versus Queen and look where now his
advantage is limited to a single pawn
and how in this position recognizing
that it's really about King position
that Wesley did not play the move h5
that was really shocking for me and
again right here you could look up the
games you can go to the the tata steel
chess website and they'll have this game
with comments by the players too by the
way very nice and you can put this
position in your chess engine and you'll
be shocked to realize that your chess
engine starts to say that black is fine
and it's you know like that even though
he will be down upon it down to ponds
the chess engine says black is fine
due to the threats to White's King and
that makes all the difference in the
world and then finally just this
position oops sorry I don't want that
position anymore
I want this position this idea that
right here it's a critical moment and
this trading rooks because Queen endings
are so notoriously drawn this idea of
trading rooks I would have I would have
avoided it as much as possible and again
asked myself that question who's King is
more vulnerable and the moment you are
meet at the moment you realize that wait
a minute after check whites King isn't
honorable no White's King is actually
actually doing wonderfully let's play
for the attack attack all right well
thank you all for coming enjoy the snow
and ice I know I will thank you